okay let's start streaming all right
perfect so what do you think about the
Chinese problem
I think we're the solution no no no
but you're American
true yeah they uh
yeah Chinese people look at me like oh a
white guy doing yellow face it is
there's a dichotomy there hey look at
you snorting whatever yeah yeah that's
gotta start off every punch strong
smells like a Band-Aid
no this is like eucalyptus what did he
get from that
a clear head
okay that's fun I mean
do you think it gives you an advantage I
think so I when I go to shows I give
this to everybody and they say like wow
I
I think I didn't bomb because of this
but don't you think that if you need to
smell something then not bomb that
you're not that funny
I think it's better than alcohol
smelling things yeah
what I mean so you think like it just
clears your sinuses and sort of puts
something in your head like little
molecules that go into your brain and
make you think better
I think it just makes you more awake so
I guess kind of thinking better but also
it's like a little slap in the face
being like let's do this yeah so it's
just like a shock to the system
basically yeah but I have other stuff
that's way stronger this is like not
that much to me at this it's like
marijuana Kinda Yeah and you have like
heroin at home
basically oh man if he told me we're
doing the Pod earlier I would have
brought it out we could have tried it
this is the same stuff that uh Joe Rogan
uses he he gave this like Mark Norman
and like Ari and all that the smelling
salts yeah like the white one but ah
yeah so it like wakes you up
oh more than that man isn't it weird how
like we're just discovering this like as
a culture don't you think it hasn't been
like really that popular until now
that's true yeah for whatever reason
especially in Asia speaking of Asia and
Chinese and uh
Thailand yeah they have this oh [ __ ]
I'll just let it yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right it's officially a trap house
oh [ __ ] I got it on the walls
it's all right just tell girls it's come
you got the biggest balls in the game
dude
[Laughter]
anyways
um yeah I mean
I think that's cool should we keep
snorting this [ __ ] yeah yeah man you can
do it like every two minutes
but in uh Thailand last time I visited
with some friends they had this powder
and it just looks like sand they call it
a nut
and you snort it and that's like makes
that look like
a Tic Tac that's nothing do you think it
clears up your sinuses this yeah
definitely I talked to people who were
like after I had coveted I can't smell
anymore
yeah and then they smell this and
they're like they kind of like woke up
my nose
now they can smell
sponsored by Hong Tai brand guys this
podcast sponsor my home tie
I mean I just think it's uh kind of
weird I don't know I'm not used to it
it's uh
it's a weird thing to do to like enhance
your
yourself with all these different things
like shouldn't you just do it naturally
just by forcing yourself to have more
energy
I can't do that I took a power nap
before I came here so I'd be ready
well luckily it took forever to set up
um but yeah that's cool you smell things
but you don't do marijuana
no not anymore I gotta do shrooms next
though I bought shrooms from a guy who
lives in a school bus so I think it's
gonna be good
yeah it's probably from the school bus
inside is made inside the school bus
probably yeah
it was called uh geometry actually
that's the Strand
that's cool so you do drugs you just
don't like to do marijuana no not really
are you is it do you think it's because
you're like type A and you're like all
infused with capitalistic energy
I mean hard working yeah like
pointlessly working to destroy the
rainforest just for promotion
just go go go doesn't matter what you're
doing no I snapped out of that like
maybe in college like halfway through
says the stream is glitchy
let me see that's what the app said
I don't know why this stream is glitchy
showing up fine for me
um
that's the camera feed though can you
see like the YouTube feed yeah what the
viewers are seeing
OBS is really [ __ ] up
it's not that glitchy look no it was
fine maybe it was
like it's a little
is that better uh I can't tell there's
like a big lag
no it's kind of wobbly now
uh bring it back to uh
where
rotate it to your side of just a little
bit this side yeah that that's good
that's good
so
what do you think about uh
doing comedy for white people
man you got a point about that man I
think I've seen like 13 Asians at comedy
shows in the last two years
yeah Asians don't really come out to
comedy shows
and they don't they don't I think my
family's accounting for half the comedy
Asian audience
I feel like Asians are when in social
situations the biggest thing is to not
[ __ ] anything up
like they're really risk adverse in
social situations so the idea of
watching an Asian bomb on stage they're
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah maybe
they wouldn't like it as much
because it's like at a comedy show like
a lot of things can go wrong you know
like right
you can
you could like get embarrassed or like
be called a Heckler and everyone judges
you and shames you and we come from like
uh World War II traumatized people so
we're like famines and you know you
think that still affects us like World
War II trauma for Asians yes
definitely more from a Japanese
perspective I'm guessing uh because of
the Japanese yeah
um but yeah I mean I feel like
everything has an impact like if you
wake up today with this with like uh you
know like and you get bad news and then
that start your day off wrong
and that affects how you act in that
evening like that's the same thing with
history like how how why wouldn't a
genocide have impact your
your you know like it it sets off a
chain reaction and everything's
connected and if you can see how things
are connected you can respond better
instead of just being like oh who cares
don't think about anything except the
moment like a dog I mean humans are very
good at planning ahead and stuff
they're also good at remembering the
past I guess never letting it go so it
kind of goes both ways except the
present mm-hmm
yeah
they think about the future and the past
hopefully
uh the hum
the hexagons are sound proofing
all right now it's gonna get hot nah
yeah we can turn it on like 20 minutes
yeah we can't go for it we can do a
podcast and Asana at the same time yeah
a hot pot
smelling salt
are you afraid like you're gonna get
your boogers on it and then someone else
is gonna get their boogers on it and
it's gonna be like
that you're going to get Noah's STDs
not at all no this is my trademark in
the comedy community they know what
they're signing up for too that is not
your jokes
that's fine
it's just something yellow fever jokes
to go around someone can just take your
whole thing by buying three dollars
worth of smelling salts
not from Thailand I can't find these
anywhere else
yeah I don't think that's a thing I
think white people don't want to change
like that they don't want to do that
they want to just have the acceptable
brain States
and that's not one of them no they love
it man they love it well not really
because it's not really a popular thing
but when you introduce it to them they
like it yeah individually
I'm just talking about it's not like
something that's accepted in this
culture to do like it's not a very you
do get looks you do get looks but why is
incense more popular now like they like
ever well it's too powerful like you can
have incense because it's in the
background you're not putting it
directly up to your nose so it's not
impacting you that much
even though it does but anything that's
not normal you can't have it impact you
too much it has to just be sort of in
the background or else you're gonna have
a different mind State than other people
and you're not going to be able to
conform and be a powerful player in your
culture true you have to use pop culture
to kind of revolutionize a product like
this like put it in a little nosex video
um
what'd you say like if I feel like if
you want to make smelling inhalants like
more popular you have to put in like a
music video like a Katy Perry music
video dude 13 year old girls like yeah
drool over like an Opie I'm dead
it's like a bunch of people sitting in a
basement just smelling things and just
be like hell yeah
[ __ ] everything
's about my personal enjoyment
I'm glad you mentioned that I'm slowly
leaning towards nihilism right now and I
don't know if that's a good thing
I know you're too good looking and this
Society has very uh very many
Temptations and Pleasures that can trap
people luckily I'm too ugly to be
impacted by any of the pleasures so I'm
I'm you know I'm immune but you're
you're like in Prime position to be
tempted and be led astray so that you
don't make uh any changes
to our society I slowly Edge away from
that I've been thinking am I more of a
nihilist or am I autistic because I'll
be talking to people and then like
halfway through the conversation just
leave because I'm like this ain't worth
my time
so you don't like talking to some people
and you think that makes you a nihilist
a little bit to where you're like this
doesn't matter it's not even fun
so you're just rude to people and it's
you don't face any negative consequences
so you're you're thinking of Leaning
into that no I don't I don't think it's
healthy
but don't you think that you should just
not open yourself up to everyone just
open yourself up to a few people that's
fair
I've been thinking about like Social
Circles what do you consider to be like
a healthy amount of close friends some
people say 30 that that doesn't sound
real at all
I don't think there's a number I think
you just uh do whatever you can
you just uh you just [ __ ] have as
many close friends as you can which
doesn't isn't that many but yeah I mean
I think like
I don't have that many close friends
which I wish I had more but
it's not like I'm trying to get a
certain amount
would you say we're close friends
because we never talk yeah but I still
enjoy your company yeah I met you at the
creek in New York
that was a long time ago and then that
night we hung out with uh your van
that was that was a memorable night I
like that it kind of scared me though
I'm not gonna lie of course I did I'm a
bad Asian you're a good Asian no you
like spooked me we were at the back of
like an open mic and then um
I I didn't even see your face you can't
kind of came up behind me and you're
like so you're the attractive Asian guy
everyone's talking about and I was like
what the [ __ ] I like covered my [ __ ]
and I was like what's this guy gonna do
who's I did I say that yeah who was
talking about you
I think I don't know like I just was
maybe three or four months in I started
doing some shows and then I guess maybe
you heard about another Asian guy doing
comedy yeah
um yeah that was a crazy way to meet I
mean I think that uh there's not a lot
of Asians so maybe I was just trying to
talk to you and that's just what I
decided to say for whatever reason
but yeah I mean I would love to uh be
close friends with more people including
you I appreciate that man thanks again
for the invite it's funny that you
mentioned having more close friends
because I was hanging out with my
girlfriend and I have a to-do list of
like little goals
and I threw it in the trash because I
already processed it but she went
through the trash and she saw Alyssa
said make three friends you're very
analytical about your
um personal life basically yeah yeah
shouldn't be more organic
that's fair yeah but I think uh after
you go to school for like the first 22
years of your life you like get caught
in the classroom
yeah mindset where you're like I gotta
do this and this yeah that's how they
indoctrinate us to you know be more
analytical and less human so that we're
easier to control you'll love and hate
this quote Rockefeller had this evil
quote he said uh I don't want a nation
of
thinkers I want a nation of workers
which is just [ __ ] evil yeah that's
what a slave owner would say
um but yeah you uh you want to make
friends and
I mean I would say that you're
neurodivergent not just because you
smell things you change your brain but
you just have like a different way of
interacting with the world and different
perspective and
you know you're very uh
uh effusive you have a lot of outbursts
good outbursts
well I'm not Outburst but like sometimes
when you're like happy it just comes out
and you don't try to hide it oh yeah
Zucker American in some ways
but uh yeah isn't it weird like this
thing like it forces your nose to open
up
it's like your nose could have opened up
before but it just didn't and it needed
the correct signal to be like open up it
does open it up this is not something
you should do before cocaine you're
gonna go through it way faster
yeah you're gonna feel it more
you're going to get way higher you're
going to get fentanyl for sure
straight into your bloodstream
but yeah it's crazy how like how off how
long I go with clogged nose with a
clogged nostril and I don't even realize
it and then I clear it I'm like oh I
should have done that way before I was
just living with one clogged nose this
whole time
and it always switches there's always
like one nostril always closed it's like
a highway construction which is your
Coke nostril I use both it's like always
under construction they gotta repair the
nose it's like the nose is so sensitive
and I think especially now because like
the pollutants in the air and the amount
of male trees that we plant right next
to each other
so that they're all releasing dandruff
or whatever sperm there's male and
female trees yeah what the hell the
female trees have fruit and we're like
we don't want fruit so let's just have a
bunch yeah it's gay we don't want
peaches yeah what the hell
yeah so then we have a bunch of male
trees and they put out a lot of what is
that called pollen pollen yeah what's
the benefit of having a male tree
besides having like bees no fruit
they don't smell because they don't
fruit and they don't rot so they're like
let's plant a bunch of male trees but
then they didn't think about it and now
we have to deal with like like the
poisonous air of all these little
particles that cause everyone to sneeze
and [ __ ]
um because we didn't respect mother
nature and we're like we can outsmart
her and just have a bunch of male trees
no I think you're just weak I don't get
allergies no one in my family gets
allergies well
maybe you guys are just snorting it and
it's just you're gonna get cancer later
because you're not sneezing it out
that's fine as long as I don't get
drowsy before 2PM
so you're willing to lose 20 years of
your life
20 years off an Asian life then you die
like 83 that's not bad
but you could have lived till 100.
I think it's I I think after 80 your
body starts to wither away I don't think
I could fast walk at 80. well it's not
like you just suddenly die at 80 if you
like live an unhealthy life it's like
your whole life is shittier
yeah it's like 20 years shittier until
you die dude I'm 26